dude I our exam my boys and I we decided
to start a lawn mowing company my one
friend had herself ja landscaping and we
were we I was 14 at the time our other
boy Jason 16 because I Mary had this
little [ __ ] truck but two lawn mowers
in the back so it's jason Joey myself
and we went around to the fancy homes
and I made business cards for everyone
made business Yung besides I ordered
business starts and it had George Jetson
on them not bad George Jetson pushing a
lawnmower so [ __ ] random and we go up
the I mean you're talking mall time
about it's like the the [ __ ] beverly
hills of denver because we're trying to
get these huge long so bad idea to speak
for [ __ ] ever and we're pitching it
to this guy and like you know there's no
business like us I'm 15 I'm like there's
no business like it and shits the
cutting is I'll tell you what if you can
explain to me why if George Jetson on a
lost landscaping card oh I'll use a
service and I SAT them like cuz cuz we
mow lawns from the future it's going to
be so good unit you think we're from the
future any other three that works and
then we started doing it but it was so
much work you so much we had we had
those little [ __ ] lawn mowers like
we should be using the right one was
practice you you're talking [ __ ]
football fields we were there all day in
our rates were twenty dollars like the
guys like of course will do this oh no
I'm so we're doing that and I remember
this one house and it was the smoke show
of the block just this single mom just
bought just a smoke show now watch too
much porn Oh back down and I was odd not
just like it's all taken care of deep do
you need anything else she like you did
you get the trash like I got all the
leaves it's like okay I'm like deep do
you need anything else like anything
when i tried had my bombing I'd have my
shirt off and just beat red from the Sun
sweat in like there's anything in the
house you need i know you know i don't i
don't know she's like get out of here
she could totally tell us like he do you
need to take down de la mona dig young
i'm smooth my dick does not go down my
dick does not go how about some
landscaping a dick suck how about that
you don't have to tell you
had a chance to do something or you
could do the whatever boxing match would
make a hundred million dollars would you
retire there or if you can make another
20 something 50 million in one more UFC
fight would you do that I would probably
stop man well again I was never world
chance to make those guys walked a
different beat but you're very
competitive to your I'm super
competitive but if you gave me a hundred
million dollars i'm not a complete [ __ ]
with my money or set man any as a kid on
the way and i think also you're going to
be singing a different tune when that
baby comes in the world your response
for that baby any like well i mean how
much head trauma do I want Ferguson
ain't could be more rough [ __ ] matter
it's not saying you can't beat them but
Stalin see they're very tough matchups
and and I have you know money put away I
flat Floyd on the biggest fight of all
time I walk away on the feet in mixed
martial arts so she's more than when the
USVI walk away undefeated he lost that
one silly fight I'm good I walked away
see ya know I think anyone go to movies
games are thrown whatever you want not
get head trauma and still keep your fame
and in the notoriety it was they make
this Floyd Connor fight there's there's
nowhere else to go but down so why wait
for the down bringing up Rhonda as the
example of what and it's been beaten to
death but she got girls to see
themselves in her and to see that they
can become something like that or not
even not again again with my girlfriend
she came to I think it was a i think it
was in Texas when I fought in that
Dallas and Juwanna j-trick she was
fighting Carla Esparza she's just like
wow that's amazing because she never
really saw that before and I think if
you can build more and more stories
whether how niche market they are and
ask Tom you have to and that's where
something I think like you have the
different markets where you can push it
the Brazil fighters in Brazil you push
the Canadian fighters in Canada and then
all the other stuff I I think it serves
its purpose for better or worse and I
think that's just the way the directions
going and I'm doing my part having a
lovely show and the movie in the works
and
owning a big piece of all of them I mean
I could see and I don't you don't have
to give me your picture on TV sure but I
could you tie them up being this free
soil that travels around I could see
going around to all these different
countries and embracing the culture and
doing these in different styles right
yeah yeah yeah I think I'm an
entertainer yeah you know I'm staying
with your personality and it's you're
not a threatening guy right and you're a
guy that people can relate to and you
like your this free spirit and I can see
travelin embraces almost like Anthony
Bourdain meets UFC no well I can either
confirm murder that my first girlfriend
ever was in the bud activities man
really first girl that after you find
out by doing them yeah well whether like
you like we I know but what she like
feel I would just love for you to
tonight you might have I can't remember
and I trust him long to remember what
the words were oh yeah I just my brain
doesn't hold him dude I hear you I lost
property amount of bowling alley
actually in our town did a bully already
guys like AMC awesome virginity standing
up wow it seems like something you would
against the wall huh against the brick
wall back there by the dumb she was
against when I was behind her teacher
Chi gandered yeah yeah pants down she
have a dress on um I think we both had
pain to a book had teenage jeans on that
girl i had sex with had one of a 16 and
kids will throw rocks at us I just
remember that anyways hold on you were
balls deep in this girl you both get
your Levi's down to your ankles and kids
are taking rocks rhinestone you too we
have mean kids god damn that's at New
Orleans [ __ ] man what do you think about
when you masturbate hmm I think about
honestly now at this point I Philip I
think a little bit about some kind of
sexual ideas you know but then I think
about how bad I'm going to feel after on
the masquerade really why do you feel
bad they pass the baton to light Shane
light of shame ouo for you are your
porno guy looks like redtube or whatever
such efficient I've been out there man
I've been in the nasty out there it is
not as nasty dude was just talking about
this on my podcast this nasty some of
these videos and people doing all these
blood activities and everything and but
activities you know the thing you they
are like you just shot it's constantly
escalating like everyone's trying to
one-up each other in the porn and I
don't want to be in it they are aren't
they it's just too much there are
don't need seven guys know what happened
just one on one it's unwise that to be a
gang banger with yeah yeah and it's so
rough whack Amole to be the road gang
bang play the job gets to like urban
lack imola really and Andrew Santino has
the best she talks about how a lot of
black gentleman always have their
sneakers on during a pornography into an
shop Sakura I never liked music foregrip
uses really rail at home rip and
probably how it makes foot is rampant
and also know as [ __ ] right off his
carpet he goes back to indoor outdoor
like those are kind of outdoor show you
to be nice in a theater when you're rich
do you know go to a poor theater dude
people are humming usually a sister
hitting you in the back of the head with
something for nothing for you to do
anything so for don't what grinds your
dude usually in the back of the head but
yeah I mean it could be an urban girl or
your actual you know blood sister okay
have you have you been an urban theater
I mean it's just like how do you just
pop it black couple is behind just
straight up top oh yeah i guess like
like there's no movie there's no
etiquette and i'm not i'm not saying
black people I'm saying urban deer which
is a mix i go this one off the ID you
better know you better hope it's a 3d
movie with all I'm yeah its interaction
for a plot your [ __ ] it's in our house
to perfect their eating green fire yeah
here is it's the [ __ ] popcorn and
damn dog you see that [ __ ]